going back to 2010 what were some of the
offers that you receive while you're at
Sundance some of the offers were just
laughable if not and when we say
laughable what it means is you get
offered zero money up front for your
film so like absolutely nothing and the
terms and which they're being offered to
you are such that really you know you'll
never see a penny from it'd be like a
penny and more than that like you
wouldn't even mind that if it was
structured in such a way that you felt
the company that was taking it was going
to spend a lot of money in advertising
and really connect it with an audience
and promote it you know in which case
you know then you weigh it up you know
if you have a company that's saying
we're not gonna give you any money and
you're not really going to get any
back-end you're not gonna see any money
for this but we're gonna be will say you
know yeah we'll spend five million
dollars promoting it well that that is
pretty decent you know because that will
enhance you and has your standing as a
filmmaker you know because the film's
gonna get out there but if really all
the distributor's gonna do and that's
the kind of I think the offers that we
had it was really like you know it's
just really to add just you know certain
companies catalogs where they will own
the rights to in perpetuity but they're
not like thousand almost ten thousand
dollars i mean it was a joke I mean some
of it was just ridiculous how many
offers did you get while you were there
I had we had two offers while we were
there and then we had another offer when
we got away from there but they were so
like I said you know 5,000 10,000 you
know really low ball offers I mean we
did get one offer which was a terrific
one we sold the rights to an alignment
ship Airlines and shipping who even you
like yeah and so we sold the rights for
that for that we took 25 thousand
dollars so that was like you know and
that was like a decent amount for
something that you know we wouldn't have
any access to any way you know so that
was that was a good deal but other than
that like actually then this sort of
selling the rights for America or
something there was nothing that domain
and then also on top of that one of the
one of the awards the Alfred P sloan
award which is the only cash prize award
at Sundance we won that so that was a
tax-free cash prize award no
strings attached so that was like 20
grand and that along with the airline
and shipping with the other deal I mean
that brought us close to our physical
budget you know that we made the movie
for so that was great the other deals
that we were being offered were almost
insulting to to an artist any artist to
a filmmaker to an artist to a musician
insulting to think that that's what you
as a company would pay this person for
their hard end work but it's not
something it's just that I mean it's
just the market right now you know it is
the fact that there's so many things out
there so they don't have a huge value
you